[موسيقى]
مرحبا والف تحيه من باريس لعلكم زرتم هذه
المدينه الجميله واشهر معالمها
لكن ستكتشفون في هذا البرنامج العاصمه
الفرنسيه اسرارا لا تعرفونها اهلا بكم في
برنامج اسرار
[موسيقى]
باريس كما للبشر كذلك للحيوانات تاريخ
وقصص في هذه الحلقه نعرفكم باسرار بعض
الحيوانات في
[موسيقى]
باريس نحن امام اقدم برج للحمام العسكري
في فرنسا شو يد بعيد انتهاء حرب العام
1870 بين البروسيين والفرنسيين حرب لعب
خلالها الحمام الزاجل دورا رئيسيا سمح
للباريسيين المحاصرين بالتواصل مع بقيه
المناطق الفرنسيه اهميه الحمام الزاجل
ودوره في ابرز الحروب التي خضتها فرنسا
موضوع هذا
التقرير سبتمبر عام
1870 القوات البروسيه تحاصر باريس من كل
الجهات حصار محكم سيدوم لاكثر من 130 يوما
كل خطوط التليغراف مقطوعه وحدها مناطيد
البريد والحمام الزاجل تؤمن التواصل مع
الخارج عشيه بدء الحصار ارسلت الى العاصمه
الفرنسيه 1500 حمامه مدربه على نقل الاف
الرسائل المصغره التي كان مطلقها يعيدون
تكبيرها على شاشات عرض جداريه وقد سعى
البروسيين الى الحد من طريقه التواصل تلك
عبر اصطياد حمام واطلاق صقور المانيه
لمهاجمتها بعد الحرب شيدت عده ابراج
لتربيه الحمام الزاجل وتدريبه وهكذا خلال
الحرب العالميه الاولى استعملت 30 الف
حمامه للتعويض عن انقطاع الاتصالات
السلكيه قضى منها خلال الحرب 20 الفا
فوحده الحمام الزاجل كان قادرا على اجتياز
المسافات القصيره رغم القصف والضباب
والدخان كما جمع الحمام الزاجل معلومات
استراتيجيه مهمه اذ ركبت اجهزه تصوير
صغيره على صدره كانت تلتقط بشكل
اوتوماتيكي صورا لمواقع العدو وكان
الالمان كلما احتل منطقه فرنسيه دمروا
فيها ابراج الحمام وعاقبوا بالاعدام من
تجرا على
تربيتها وتم اللجوء مجددا الى الحمام
الزاجل خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه لكن
الاحتلال النازي لفرنسا عط عملها لفتره
قصيره لاسما وان الالمان منعوا بعد الغزو
استعمال اجهزه الراديو وتربيه الحمام على
التراب الفرنسي لكن عندما تنظم صفوف
المقاومه في فرنسا قام البريطانيون بانزال
اكثر من 16000 حمامه بمظلات صغيره فوق
المناطق المحتله ما ساعد المقاومين
الفرنسيين على تزويد لندن بالمعلومات بعد
حرب الهند الصينيه وحرب الجزائر توقف
الفرنسيون عن استخدام الحمام الزاجل في
المعارك اليوم لا يزال الجيش الفرنسي يربي
هذا النوع من الحمام في حصن مون فالان
العسكري بضواحي باريس داخل الحصن اخر برج
في اوروبا لتربيه الحمام الزاجي هنا يتم
تدريب 160 حمامه احياء لتقليد عسكري اراد
الجنرال دجول ان يستمر لكن لو لزم الامر
فان الحمام الزاجله الفرنسي جاهز من جديد
لتلبيه نداء
الواجب نحن الان في المتحف الوطني للتاريخ
الطبعي وسط باريس وما ترونه خلفي هو وحيد
قرن الملك لويس الخامس عشر كان اول حيوان
بهذا الحجم يتم تحنيطه في فرنسا في حياته
عرف النجوميه وقتل خلال الثوره الفرنسيه
قصه مدهشه نسرد لكم ابرز محطاتها في هذا
التقرير عشيه يوم من ايام صيف العام
1769 وصلت الى مرفا مدينه لوغون غرب فرنسا
سفينه محمله بهديه خاصه للملك وحيد قرن
هندي اهداه حاكم مدينه شندر ناجار للويس
الخم عشر رحلته البحريه من شمال البنغالي
الى فرنسا استغرقت سته اشهر ولم تخلو من
مصاعب جمه ورحله البريه من لغيان الى
حديقه الحيوانات الملكيه في فيرساي دامت
بضعه اشهر اضافيه لا سما بعد ما انكسرت
العربه التي صنعت خصيصا له تحت وطاه وزنه
طيله 22 عاما عرض على العامه في حظيره
بداخلها بركه ماء صغيره وذاع صيته كحيوان
شرس وعنيف لا سما بعدما قتل شابين تجرا
على الاقتراب منه
لكن ذلك لم يفسد نجوميته فقد كانت له
شعبيه واسعه تماما كوحده قرن اخرى تدعى
كلارا كانت تقوم انذاك بعروض في مختلف
انحاء اوروبا وبفضله ما راجت موضه حقيقيه
في فرنسا تجلت في الكتب والمنحوتات
والساعات وحتى في تسريحات الشعر والازياء
النسائيه لكن خلال الثوره الفرنسيه قرر
بعض الثوار تحرير حيوانات حديقه الحيوانات
التي اعتبروها ضحيه ايضا للسلطه الملكيه
الا انهم عدلوا عن قرارهم عند مشاهدتهم
الاسد ووحيد القرن فتقرر نقلهما من فيرساي
الى حديقه النباتات الوطنيه وسط باريس بيد
ان وحيد القرن لم يبلغ العاصمه حيا فقد
وجد مقتولا بضربه سيف في البركه وسط
حظيرته ولو ان الروايه الرسميه قالت وقتها
انه قضى غرقا
بعد ثلاثه اسابيع تم تشريحه وتحنيطه ويروى
ان الذي قام بالتحنيط توفي بعد سنه جراء
جرثومه التقتها خلال عمليه التشريح فهل
كان هذا يا ترى انتقام وحيد القرن من
ابناء
البشر لطالما اصطاد الانسان الحيوانات
لكنه كان احيانا السبب في اختفائها نهائيا
عن وجه الارض نحن الان في صاله الاجناس
المهدده وال
في المتحف الوطني للتاريخ الطبيعي ومعنا
اليوم ليحدثنا عن الاجناس المنقرض الاستاذ
جاك و احد امناء هذا
المتحف
je نحن الان امام حيوان يشبه الحمار
الوحشي ما كان اسمه
وقرض
un nom peut un peu mais qui vient en
fait de la mani dont les autant nomai
cet animal d'a son cri ce qui vous donal
une id du lieu o l'animal vivait puis
parle de plain du centre et du sud de
l'afrique du sud des grandes plaines
herbe ce qui a d'ailleurs la cause de la
disparition de l'animal qui accus en
fait de faire concurrence au bta et au
moutons qui av besoin de cette herbe
pour se nourrir donc il s'agit d'une
guerre de l'homme contre cet animal
dont la chta para excellente et dont la
peau facilement travailler pour pouvoir
faire des objets ou des pares de vts et
donc l'animal a disparu la fin du 19e
sicle je vous propose
[موسيقى]
deut
كذ disparu c'est un ser particulier on
l'appelle le de chour alors chour c'est
un nom qui para un peu pour un animal
qui vient de tha puisque telit son
habitat naturel mais en fait il a nom en
l'honneur d'un consul britannique qui en
poste en
18 date laquelle on a iden ce une esp
nouvelle on raconte d'ailleurs que on
repit ces ser simplement au bois quip
des hautes herbes et c'est ce qui a caus
en partie sa perte puis chass la vue de
ses bois mais outre la chasse ce qui a
cause de sa disparition c'est surtout la
modification trs profonde de son habitat
ces espaces ontt transform pour la
ris tel point que les ont chass et n'ont
pas pu s'adapter d'autres milieux
le dernier individu est connu dub du
20e sicle on parle de 1938 qui vivait
captif dans un temple du sud du pays
celui-ci est consid comme le seul au
monde entier poursuivre balade laver
d'autres animaux
[موسيقى]
نحن الان امام طائر الودو الشهير الذي
انقرض في القرن السا عش كم جنس من
الحيوانات مسؤول نحن البشر
عنها
dispar end de mace queb les navigateur
sur cette pour pour rita pourer et du
coup le dodo avec masse vous ch qu'il
repr cit une proie facile le dernier a
disparu en
1681 ilit trs facile attraper puis ne
vole pas il court assez maladroit mais
ce qui aal l'une des causes de sa
disparition et bien c'est
essentiellement le fait que les rats les
chats et les chiens dbar par les
navigateur consom les ufs et les jeun de
de l'p alors plus gal parlant et le dodo
illustre vit
disparition des animaux cause de
l'homme effectivement manifeste la
chasse tout disparu on estime de la
sorte que depuis l'ane 16 480 esp de
grande
taille على هذ الم mer au revir au revoir
bonte et bi merci bi
[موسيقى]
بهذا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه عن اسرار
الحيوانات في باريس من هنا من حديقه
الحيوانات والنباتات وسط العاصمه الفرنسيه
اودعكم على نلقاكم في حلقه مقبله من اسرار
بريس
[موسيقى]
ا